what's going on guys this is rob and
with future movies coming out from both
Fox and Disney based on the Marvel
Comics I thought it'd be pretty fun to
sort of go back and talk about a
different Marvel character some of whom
are some of my favorites some of whom
have have or have had a major impact on
the immortal to online or some who are
just obscure but deserve a little more
attention and I figured this first video
can be about a guy named mastermind or
as most people know he and jason
wyngarde jason wyngarde was really kind
of this interesting character he wasn't
a major figure and the Marvel Comics for
a while you know when I first sat down
and started making videos about Marvel
Comics I had never in a million years
actually dreamed that my channel would
grow this fast you know I never really
saw this is something that would happen
if anything I really kind of felt like
I'd really be kind of joining the masses
and something that had already been done
and something that had already been
established really kind of talking about
comic books because when you look on
youtube there's so many channels that
discuss comic books there's so many
people that talk about comic books in a
wide array of different ways sometimes I
just do podcast sometimes they just kind
of use still images and and my goal was
to really kind of bring what I thought
was my knowledge my not necessarily
expertise but my experience with mobile
comics to YouTube in a way that I hoped
people would kind of look at it and say
this guy is very good at explaining
things that I could really kind of build
this community really kind of build this
community of subscribers you know who
had questions and really wanted a place
to go to where they could find great
content
and over the last three or four months
that my channel has been around it's
been an astonishing adventure it has
been so incredible to really kind of sit
down and to be able to create content
that people are so excited to see that
people are so anxious to see how to
start a series and to get to kind of
that one cliffhanger that everybody
loves and for people to say bring us
more stuff bring us more content we love
your content you know and it's very
humbling it's very humbling to sit down
and to see that I as an individual I am
so well received by people out there and
YouTube by people from all walks of life
by mothers and fathers of grandparents
and grandchildren and aunts and uncles
and people from all over the world you
know that really kind of look at my
videos and say this guy just is amazing
at what he does you know I think that
people kind of have this tendency to
maybe become arrogant to really kind of
become very full of themselves in the
sense that they be themselves as
something beyond what anybody is capable
of but I don't feel like what I do is
anything wildly spectacular I sit down
and I create videos about Marvel Comics
the best way that I can to bring the
best possible content that I can and I
just wanted to take this time to say
thank you to you guys to say thank you
to anybody who's watched my video
anyone's that's given me any piece of
advice anyone that has you know stop for
a moment and given me a comment that
said your content is great or even those
individuals who weren't necessarily a
big fan of the content that I brought
and really kind of voice their concern
by saying here's things you can do
better here's a step you can take in a
better direction so thank you everybody
for 10,000 subscribers and here's
looking at you guys for 10,000 more
grows from being a baby referring to
hank pym as daddy to an adult referring
to hank pym as father and this is when
the most interesting part of ultron
begins to manifest itself and this is
the Oedipus complex that Ultron suffers
from now the Oedipus complex is a phrase
that was coined by Sigmund Freud and a
psychoanalytical concepts but the idea
of the Oedipus complex actually
originates with a Greek mythological
character named Oedipus who killed his
father and married his mother now this
is actually the idea to the play hamlet
is based off of however we see that
Ultron overpowers Hank Pym and he wipes
the memories of Ultron from Hank Tim's
mind and also implants a desire in Hank
Pym to never return to his laboratory so
once he is discovered once Hank Pym is
discovered by his wife Jan van dyne is
assumed that the destruction that has
taken place is the result of some sort
of experiment that has gone awry and
Hank Pym because he knows nothing about
Ultron doesn't really know anything
enough to refute this and so he and Jan
van dyne leave and they take up
residence at the Avengers mansion